uh I want to start with saying how much
I enjoyed this movie uh this is one of
your best films like this is this is
just really good but before we get into
this film
um if someone has actually never seen
anything you've directed before what is
the first thing you want them watching
and why you know I I showed my girls the
movies in order
um because they represented you know me
in a different movement of uh wherever I
was you know from a kid to here
um so probably I would just say watch
them in order uh because they speak to
me one one's a kind of a reaction to the
other or or a movement from one to the
next so probably like that sure when I
spoke to a few years ago I forget when
you told me you had like your next three
or four projects figured out wouldn't
tell me what they were yeah but like you
had your stuff together so at this
moment right now yeah where are you in
terms of your future and how many
projects you have in your mind for the
future yeah it's a really odd moment um
both very wonderful and and confusing
because I have three movie ideas so
three movie ideas I
too I I'm there I even have the
structure of all three to some extent
and so it's a very very weird and
interesting situation I'm feeling you
know I wish I could tell them faster you
know I wish I could get there faster but
there is no shortcut I have to bend the
six to nine months to write it I have to
storyboard for three months and then
then we have to pre-production and then
shooting in an edit for as long as I can
get every single second you know I just
finished knocking like the like that
like I would say the three hours four
hours before I put my pencils down on
knock of the cabin I added one more line
like I called an actor and I was like
say this into your phone and and send it
to me right now I have an idea and put
this and I put it in it was like that
you know one last idea and then they
were like pencils down you can't you
can't put another idea in it so
basically you're saying that like
literally every two years from now for
the next six years most likely there'll
be a movie definitely but I'm hoping to
do it a tiny bit faster than that let's
see if my if I can handle it you know
um what servant taught me was wow
there's a there's a beauty to
um creating uh when you have a lot there
a lot of things on your table that you
don't I like me as a human being I don't
spend as much time
angsting and I spend more time doing so
and and the doing makes the iteration
process quicker because I'm doing it and
it doesn't work or does work and I'm
like oh it doesn't you know and so I
stopped being so precious because I'm
there was just an enormous amount of
work to do on servant so one floor of a
building had servant and one had knocked
at the cabin running upstairs and this
side and an editor would show me
something here or composer would show me
something here and I'd say move this
movement needs to go like that and you
just go to the next question it was
almost like playing multiple games of
Chess at the same time and I found that
I stayed healthier rather than
retreating to my unhealthy version of
myself of you know imposter syndrome or
being destructive or whatever it is you
know ego driven stuff that I was just
reacting to the material definitely have
to know servant obviously the big hit on
Apple
um uh do you have another TV idea or are
you is that something that still
interests you it is I I don't think I
could do that anymore where I was doing
everything where um every sound effect
every every music you everything was
coming through me I would love to find
uh a fellow showrunner or show runner
that I could help that I could help with
her voice or his voice and
um help them get to the Finish Line I
gotta be honest I think you're too much
of a micromanager
so I don't no don't say that don't say
that that's gonna scare off everybody no
but I mean like I think you are because
you're very passionate about your stuff
and you know but it's one of the reasons
why your name is synonym you know with
quality it's because of who you are I'm
hoping that that there's a healthy
balance in the future that we can find
for something like that you've done
cameos and all your projects The Cameo
and this is spectacular which is your
favorite cameo in all your films you
know sometimes I'm not in the films
because I just can't I you know it
doesn't seem right and this one I
thought for sure I'm not going to be in
that's what that's what I thought for
sure and then in pre-production I was
like you know what would be that's I
have a funny idea and then uh we then
everybody enjoyed the concept so much I
was like all right let's go shoot it was
the first thing we shot this thing
that's uh in knock at the cabin and I
was like oh this is never going to end
up in the movie and and it did and the
editor was like I love it it's so funny
and I was like you sure it is is this
your favorite one I think the degree of
difficulty was the the highest of how to
get in there sure
um so this is adapt jumping into your
film yeah yeah this is adapted from a
book and you've definitely made changes
from the book there's a huge change in
terms of the daughter
um and I'm curious where how did you
figure out what you wanted to change and
how nervous were you to change something
like
well it I was very organic you know the
movie came to me as a producing entity
uh where the writers and the directors
who were on made it wanted to make a
straight adaptation of the book just
word you know moment for moment straight
application and that's how it came to me
and then I said I love this premise so
deeply and I think you guys are on to
something I really do I don't believe in
the story when it went left I it just I
can't get behind that and I think my
audience
uh I wouldn't want to have them
experience that that's what I said and I
said I totally support you and I wish
you the best and then they went and it
didn't come together that movie and then
organically the book came back to me and
they said
we loved what you were saying about I
said what I thought it should happen and
and where the story should go and then
they said we really believe in what you
just said and I said huh then I was
thinking about it and I thought
I believe in this this premise so much
I'm having that irrational connection to
it and I could see myself working on it
for a year and a half from there and so
I said you know what I'm actually going
to do it myself and um so it was very
beautiful on the way it kind of came
organically back and they jumped up and
down we're excited because it meant that
it was going to get made yes
um you shot with two directors of
photography on this they both worked on
servant one of them shot the lighthouse
and I mean Jarvan is you know his work
is great yeah how did you end up with
two DPS you know it was a scheduled
thing Jaron ended up doing all the
interiors and not every single interior
but almost all of them and then Lowell
did the exteriors you know so with kind
of there was an organic place in the
schedule where we could make that happen
and it was very I was very lucky to have
both of them there I love them both
they're uh good human beings really
bother them that and obviously I love
them because I worked with them on
servant and I was like hey let's let's
do this together and I love working with
new people and
um Jaron is just a very special mind the
way he thinks about lighting and if I
mean it's very complex way we shot the
cabin and there's no lights inside so
that we didn't use any lights there were
no bounces nothing it's just coming from
the windows and the doors and so uh very
naturalistic way to shoot on a stage and
it creates a very beautiful difficult
difficult to you know exposed to
difficult all of that stuff to work
around because if you move a little bit
like this then you see the lights in all
the windows so you have to adjust
everything uh it's it's a tedious
process but it it yields something very
beautiful uh it also looks like it's
shot on location yeah you know because
of that yeah because of that yeah
exactly
um so you have some really good use of I
really like the aesthetic and how you
shot this and I loved the use of
close-ups yeah and I'm curious if you
could talk a little bit about why you
wanted close-ups in certain scenes you
know if you think about this the
language of Cinema and wide shots mint
shots and and then close-ups
um they are different ways that that the
characters are interacting with their
environment so you might let's say if
you were you were in a hostage situation
like that and I'm thinking about Escape
I might be talking to you but I'm
thinking about how to get out and I
could do that in a wide shot because
that's conveying that the character is
saying hey you know it's gonna be all
right I'm you know no I'm fine fine but
I'm thinking about the windows and the
doors and you see me like struggling
um if there's a specific thing that I'm
I'm feeling
um I tend to do it closer like they're
very I'm like if you I'm trying to
ascertain whether you're crazy or you're
gonna hurt me right now I'm in hyper
close-up with you I'm watching your
facial expressions I don't really care
about your legs and so the movie starts
with a gunshot right it starts
immediately with the strangers showing
up and so there's a lot of close-ups
because they're at a nine from almost go
I'm you know you're with your daughter
and strangers break in your house you're
at a nine you know and you need to get
out of here
uh you know I like talking about the
editing process yeah so let's talk about
um how this film changed in the editing
yeah and did you have a much longer cut
you know the movie the movie's my
shortest screenplay
um uh um Noemi who cut it
um is a very beautiful editor she's as
sharp in her editing and physical as she
is uh uh her ability to assess
performance which is you know the most
important thing you know to be able to
Arc characters performances with me and
having a sense of that you know so she
has both muscles the muscularity to keep
it going but the delicacy of picking the
right performances it was uh basically
we squeeze and squeeze and squeeze and
squeezed it to get to the essence of it
because
um we what is too much to be said how do
we it became you know um I was amazed at
how much we squeeze it and when you
watch it it's breathless because we we
took everything out that we that every
line every redundancy that we could
think of we pulled out and so it's a
harsh part of the process as you do that
if you're honest with yourself and
you're and you're moving towards
um this one thing this movement like
that and there's a lot of you know
rewriting that's going on I wish the
character said that and then you know I
I do that line or we do reshoots and I
make sure I get those things I wish that
this scene ended with this and so it's a
very complicated organic process of
listening to the story and how you watch
it if me and her watch it in the editing
room then I have a little theater at
home and we watch it with the crew then
it has a different feeling but that's
different than when we put it with 200
people in an audience and those are
three different versions of the same cut
and you have to be honest with yourself
about the only one that matters is that
last one with the audience no 100 so I'm
just gonna see what you'll tell me I
know you're you have a release state of
your next movie what what can you tease
fans of yours about the next one God
there's one thing I want to tell you so
badly
I'm just dying to tell you and then when
we meet later for that movie you're
gonna tell me what was that so there's
this thing I'm dying to tell you about
it which is super special to me
I I was I I'll tell you let me see what
can I tell you I was
I was kind of it's interesting both this
last one meaning knock at the cabin
because I was thinking of it for
somebody else right I was thinking of it
as a as a mentor or as a as a producer
for those for other people so I was
thinking about what it should be and in
a very organic way and then it came to I
decided to do that version because I
felt so deeply about it same thing
happened with this I was thinking about
it as something for someone else to
direct as an idea for someone else to
direct and I just kept on thinking about
it and thinking about it and I was like
well then this could happen and that
could happen oh my God and then this
could happen oh no and then this
happened and then I've got to the whole
thing and I was like I'm gonna do this
the same exact thing happening again
maybe it's one of those things like you
said I can never let go of it but you
know
I'm telling you this is the thing do you
want to tell me the title or no
I heard the voice off camera
I want to tell you the title I really do
I can tell well when you're ready to say
it you should reach out to me and be
like and here's the title of the new M
nightmare okay great you know what I
mean but listen man congrats on this
it's really fantastic thank you brother